hi my name is anissa Ramirez welcome to
my lab at Yale University today I'd like
to talk to you about our old friend the
Sun the Sun is huge it's a hundred and
nine times the size of the earth and we
scientists would like to capture and
store some of its energy in something
small like this a battery and we can do
this with clever materials the clever
materials that I'm talking about our
solar materials or photovoltaics these
materials can convert sunlight into
electricity and they allow us to capture
energy from a cheap and plentiful source
our old friend the Sun this can help
curb our dependence on oil every hour
the Sun produces enough energy to power
our entire planet for a whole year
that's a lot of energy how do we harness
this energy what materials does it take
to make this possible the answer is
basking on the beach sand makes solar
materials possible sand is melted and
then purified into its pure elemental
form of silicon silicon is then cast
into large logs or ingots which we slice
like bread into very thin wafers silicon
wafers are the beginnings of a solar
cell but in order to create a solar cell
we've got to think about sandwiches we
need to stack these wafers on top of
each other one of the layers is slightly
negative we add phosphorus to that
another layer is slightly positive we
add a little bit of boron to that we
fuse those together we put that into the
sunlight and that's when the science
happens the Sun shines light on the
silicon sandwich and it provides enough
energy to break bonds between the
silicon broken bonds means that
electrons are free to move when
electrons move from one layer to the
other voila we have electricity so you
see when it comes to converting sunlight
into electricity it's as simple as pie
or in this case it's as simple as a
sandwich let's look at solar materials
in action here I have some solar cars
right now they're standing still
let's see what happens when I add just a
little bit of light to this situation
wow those cars really took off and with
new inventions and new governmental
policies Solar will take off too by
covering sunny places like parts of
Arizona and covering our roofs and roads
with solar panels will be able to
capture some of the energy that we need
and the extra energy that we make in the
daytime we can save for the nighttime
solar really has us covered so as you
can see solar materials are one of the
many marvels to help get the power that
we need small silicon sandwiches that
can convert sunlight into electricity
will help keep our world spinning I'm
Aneesa Ramirez thank you for joining me
in my lab at Yale University and I hope
that you'll join us for another material
marvel